when Colombia legalized medical
marijuana in 2016 entrepreneurs like
Mauricio PS Chacon thought it would be a
lucrative business to get into the red
tape political opposition and no clear
path for international trade has meant
he hasn't sold a single Bud he's had to
let go most of his workers but a new
Bill in Congress might finally open a
legal market for his product
we were allowed to produce we're allowed
to grow we're allowed to do everything
but then we don't have anybody to sell
it to the internal Market the adult use
is gonna It's Gonna Save A Lot of
companies like ours it's time we we say
hey let's not leave this up to the
cartels let's let's do it uh with the
country uh we've been we've put too many
tests on the road for this we've been on
the front line doing uh putting all the
dead people it's time we can regulate it
the arrival of Gustavo Pedro Colombia's
first left his president has opened the
door to the legalization of marijuana
for recreational use
Petra has been vocal about ending what
he calls the failed war against drugs
especially in countries like Colombia a
word that has killed more than a million
people in Latin America without denting
the power of drug trafficking mafias
sponsors of the bill say regulating the
marijuana Market will improve the life
of many rural Colombians who have long
cultivated a plant for lack of legal
profitable alternatives
or people are the ones dying we are the
ones being stigmatized we are the ones
who saw how the mafia money eroded our
society institutions we need a new way
to fight this battle against drugs with
regulations and public health the
wide-ranging law aims to change a
constitutional article that prohibits
The Possession and use of Narcotics it
would allow people to cultivate up to 20
plans for personal use while licenses
will be issued to producers and
dispensaries the tax revenues would be
reinvested in areas affected by drug
trafficking and to publicize health
risks yet despite the Progressive
Majority in Congress the fate of the
bill remains uncertain in a country that
continues to see marijuana as a gateway
drug totally frown upon
Colombia has long been the world's
largest cocaine producer and while
regulating marijuana will not end its
drug-related violence a growing number
of people and politicians here believe
it's time to try a different approach
Alessandra Al Jazeera Bogota